devo dire che sono sempre più
mio agio in cucina nel backstage che qui
su questo bel pò
di questa opportunità ho pensato di
farvi prendere carta e penna
anzi no pentola acque pasta così nel
frattempo nel tempo in cui vorrei
spiegare questo mio modo di vedere il
tempo e il tempo armonico nel mio mondo
potete anche praticare una ricetta una
ricetta che va un po contro quella che è
la tradizione ancora quando parlo di
tradizione intendo anche qui il tempo
che si butta nell'innovazione
velocemente poi iniziano a parlare su
quello che è il tema principale di
questo intervento pentola a secco
mettiamo una pasta scegliete una
qualsiasi pasta di grano duro di qualità
corta fa terza del fuoco fatelo tostare
quando sentirete profumi del cereale il
profumo della farina il profumo del
grano e vedrete il colore potete
iniziare a bagnare la vostra vostra
pasta è cominciata una cultura molto
lenta in napoletano credo civic a
picchiare piano piano piano ma lasciate
in un angolo
il tempo di cottura di questa pasta di
qualità è il tempo che io mi dedico
adesso mi prendo adesso per poter
raccontare un po quello che è il mio
mondo nel tempo e nell'armonia ribadisco
della tradizione della cucina per cui
abbiamo la nostra pasta in un angolo
della stufa che cucina naturalmente non
anche in questo caso una pasta molto
innovativa e alla fine vi dirò perché
cos'è il tempo il tempo credo che la
cosa una frase fatta di questi di
quest'ultimo periodo che sento è il più
bel regalo la più bella cosa che ognuno
di noi possa avere e avere del tempo per
sé e nessuno per lo meno io non riesco
mai a tre cerchi ma non lo trovo credo
però andando a fondo che se vogliamo
mettere a fuoco il nostro quotidiano per
tutti
un modo molto pop molto democratico per
vedere questo punto di vista
e quando noi mangiamo ci dedichiamo del
tempo che sia un panino pausa pranzo che
sia una cena con amici che sia un grande
dimmer di gala
noi ci dedichiamo del tempo quindi credo
che già partendo da questo possiamo dire
per lo meno posso dire di essere
fortunato perché nel momento in cui io
mangio so che mi sto dedicando del tempo
non sono nè quel tempo che non amo molto
che è quello social ahimè non si può
dire lo dico lo detto perché ti porta a
una velocità che non è una velocità
umana non mi appartiene nella velocità
che mi appartiene perché è troppo
immediato è troppo veloce il modo di
giudicare o di essere giudicati o di
capire o far finta di capire per cui
dopo tutto credo di fare un mestiere che
appartiene all'uomo cioè quello della
cucina a quello del cucinare o aggiunto
al tempo la parola armonia perché credo
che nell'inconscio tutti quanti noi
vorremmo avere una vita armonica sia
nelle relazioni con le persone sia nel
mio caso nella cucina sia nel lavoro a
verona ricard monica vuol dire stare
bene provare a stare bene e l'armonia
nella cucina è quella che io cerco nei
piatti che poi alla fine la traduco come
equilibrio di contrasti che poi che poi
vi racconterò verso la fine l'armonia
l'armonia del tempo e ciò che mi fa
stare bene il tempo nella cucina e nello
specifico si identifica come una cosa
semplicissima con le stagioni
per cui quando si dice non andare contro
il tempo quando si dice utilizzare il
prodotto di stagione perché a famiglia
tutte queste cose le ho imparate dalla
mia prima da mia madre la mia prima
maestra della cucina che sin da piccolo
mi ha abituato a mangiare il prodotto di
stagione perché perché faceva bene e
perché
diventava accessibile alla famiglia per
cui una sostenibilità della famiglia
quando presenta il mio caso il caso del
ristorante do qualche anno fa ad harvard
o presentati come apply decò nomi noti
ore tikal economy sono due parole o nei
grandi che sono le parole che io ho
imparato stando vicino a mia madre prima
a cucinare anzi a mangiare più delle
volte e poi stando a fianco dei grandi
maestri quindi parlo di gualtiero
marchesi alain ducas pierné a parigi
albert rua le gavroche a londra per cui
ho visto sempre questa cosa come un
punto in più per poter cucinare bene nel
tempo per cui il cucinare bene del tempo
vuol dire utilizzare come dicevo la
stagione vuol dire tradizione e
innovazione perché perché anzitutto non
si può fare innovazione se non si
conosce la tradizione per conoscere la
tradizione bisogna non solo studiarla
bisogna prenderla a bottega come come ha
fatto come capitato nel con il mondo
della cucina
bisogna praticarla
bisogna imparare a bisogna assorbirla e
poi naturalmente anche studiarla però il
passaggio per poter fare innovazione nel
mondo della cucina credo sia proprio
quello della conoscenza perfetta della
tradizione per potersi innovare se non
si conosce la tradizione sicuramente una
possibilità di innovazione e questi sono
due punti fermi per quello che riguarda
il mio modo di vedere di vedere la
cucina e di vedere il mondo il mondo che
mi che mi contorna l'armonia vuol dire
nel tempo questo l'ho imparata vuol dire
non ripetere gli stessi ingredienti in
un menù questo lo scriveva escoffier nel
1860 sulla linea per cui se ci pensiamo
un un tema scritto così tanti anni fa
ancora attuale anzi ancor più attuale
oggi perché non ripetendo colori i gusti
consistenze prodotti si arriva ad avere
una cucina armoniosa e una cucina che fa
bene perché alla fine il fuoco deve
essere quella persona che alla base deve
nutrire in maniera corretta i propri
ospiti i propri amici e deve qualcuno
dice poter far sognare si ci può stare
ma credo fermamente che un cuoco
classico come la mia impostazione e
altrettanto moderno per l'innovazione
che o debba essere un qualcosa che io
possa fare per le persone a cui facciamo
mangiare nel miglior modo possibile per
nutrire e far star bene
molte volte con questa facilità che
abbiamo nella società si è passati al
fatto del del cibo che sia diventato
solo un divertimento per cui molte volte
si nutre male perché il cibo viene
trattato come amico viene trattato come
un qualcosa a cui dare del tu credo che
il maggior rispetto per il cibo per
poter far sì che noi possiamo stare bene
si debba dare con lei
bisogna prenderlo gli dico sempre con le
pinze proprio perché è il nostro miglior
amico nel caso noi riusciamo ad
estrapolare il meglio e il meglio come
dicevo è quello che arriva dalla
stagione si parla in cucina di molte
volte d arte di artisti si parla di
talento io credo credo a tutte queste a
tutte queste cose ma su alcune non sono
molto d'accordo credo che la cucina sia
un risultato di un cammino di una
carriera di una persona di una passione
di una persona sia un risultato di tante
cose tante esperienze messe come per
costruire una casa al mattone sopra
l'altro che garantisca prima con le basi
con le fondamenta importanti che
garantisca la casa di non cadere per cui
credo che il tracciato di di essere
cuoco di essere una persona che ama
alimentare le altre persone debba essere
fatto con una linearità e una coerenza
estrema quindi dicevo nel talento il
talento è fondamentale e credo che sia
una cosa che alla quale tutti possono
attingere non credo che il talento sia
per pochi credo che il talento ce lo
possono avere tutti solo se collegato a
un filo di umiltà quindi vedere il
talento senza umiltà potrebbe essere
come vedere il tempo senza il giorno il
alici senza il paese delle meraviglie il
polso senza battito e quando si su
questo libro sul talento
mi ricordo ormai 14 anni fa dicevo uno
stadio a porte chiuse su questo punto
credo dovrò dovrò rivedermi per cui io
credo che senza talento si possa farlo
in poco e con il pizzico di umiltà si
possa conquistare veramente tante
soddisfazioni e si possa conquistare il
mondo adesso chiudo con la ricetta
intanto che picchiava la pasta in angolo
la portiamo al centro dell'attenzione
vedremo che l'acqua che abbia ammesso è
evaporata vedremo che ci sarà una già
una pasta succulenta di per sé perché è
la mida della pasta non l'abbiamo
scolato come d'abitudine si fa con la
pasta normale quindi tanta acqua tanta
tanta cosa che tanta acqua che buttiamo
quindi diventa anche un piatto di pasta
sostenibile perché l'acqua evaporata è
rimasta dentro la pasta è già condita
aggiungere un pizzico di sale
una grattugiata di freschezza che può
essere una buccia di agrumi limone
un pizzico di arancia pompelmo due
foglioline di menta e basilico
magari qualche pisellino fresco perché
entriamo nella stagione bella del colore
verde e il mio piatto che i 15 18 minuti
di ted può rappresentare la mia idea di
tempo